This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When producer Ellie Gordon Marshall was growing up, she played baseball, tennis, soccer, ice hockey, field hockey, flag football, volleyball, field lacrosse, box lacrosse, I don't even know what that one is. Basically I played whatever I could find. If there's a team, a moving object, and points to be had, I'm probably pretty good at it. Ellie is an only child, and she didn't really think of her parents as sports people.
这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马斯。当制作人埃莉·戈登·马歇尔（Ellie Gordon Marshall）在成长过程中，她打过棒球、网球、英式足球、冰球、草地曲棍球、腰旗橄榄球、排球、室外长曲棍球、室内长曲棍球——我甚至都不知道最后那个是什么。基本上，我能找到什么运动就玩什么。如果有队伍、有移动的物体、还有得分的机会，我大概都很擅长。埃莉是个独生女，她以前并不觉得自己的父母是热爱运动的人。
To be fair, my dad sometimes went out for runs, but in short shorts I found very embarrassing, so I blocked it out. You have to take care of yourself in this world. Still, for years, I thought I was the only one in my family that truly understood the appeal of the sweat, blood, and tears of sport. That is until I came across my mom's high school yearbooks. So you guys were called the rockets. Yes. And the boys were called the rockets. I wouldn't say the rocks, but yeah. This is me talking to my mom a few years ago.
平心而论，我爸爸有时会去跑步，但他穿着的那种短裤让我觉得很尴尬，所以我自动屏蔽了这一幕。在这个世界上，你得顾及自己的形象。不过多年来，我一直以为我是家里唯一真正懂得欣赏运动中挥洒的汗水、鲜血和泪水所具有的魅力的人。直到我偶然翻到我妈妈的高中毕业纪念册。所以你们以前被称为“火箭队”。是的。男生们也被称为“火箭队”。我不敢说他们是巨石，但差不多吧。这是我几年前和我妈妈的对话。
We were pouring over memories from her time on the high school basketball team back in the 1960s. Yeah, here you can see. The team ended the season with a 9-16 record. In one photo, all the girls are sitting straight laid on the gym floor. They're in sort of a semi-circle around a basketball showing off their straight socks.
我们当时正在细细品味她20世纪60年代在高中女子篮球队时的回忆。对，这里你可以看到。球队以 9 胜 16 负的战绩结束了那个赛季。在一张照片里，所有的女孩都直直地坐在体育馆的地板上。她们围着一个篮球呈半圆形坐着，展示着她们笔直的长袜。
There's also photos of the team goofing around, which I love, but my favorite picture of my mom is her practice leaping up to defend a player she still remembers. This is Donna Kraus, who was like the star on the team. She's shooting a basket, and you can tell there's no way I'm gonna block her shot. In the practice photos, everyone looks so cool and athletic with their white sneakers and socks.
照片里还有球队在恶作剧的画面，我非常喜欢。但我最喜欢我妈妈的一张照片，是她练习起跳防守一个她至今仍记得的球员。这是唐娜·克劳斯（Donna Kraus），她当时就像是队里的明星。她在投篮，你可以看出我是绝对盖不到她的帽的。在训练照片中，每个人穿着白色的运动鞋和袜子，看起来都那么酷、那么有运动细胞。
But in the game photos, some things looked off. The uniforms, for example. The tops, they were kind of crop tops so that when you, you know, shot a basket or moved your arms up, you could actually see your stomach. Yeah, I heard an entire mid-drip is exposed. And I remember looking at these when I was a teenager
但在比赛照片中，有些地方看起来怪怪的。比如队服。上衣有点像露脐装，所以当你，你知道的，投篮或者把手臂向上抬时，你真的能看到你的肚子。对，我听说整个腹部都露出来了。我记得当我还是个青少年的时候看到这些照片时，
and such a tomboy, I was like horrified. Yeah, horrified because when I saw the uniforms, I could not imagine playing any sport at that age in a satin-y shirt that barely covered my stomach. And that wasn't the only thing my mom told me that sounded weird about her days playing basketball. There were also the rules. Ellie's mom played basketball, but not the five on five basketball we know today. She played six on six Iowa girls basketball. There were three forwards and three guards. So as the three guards, you guarded the other team's three forwards. In six on six basketball, the three forwards only play offense.
而且还是个假小子，我当时简直吓坏了。没错，吓坏了，因为当我看到那些队服时，我无法想象自己在那个年纪，穿着一件几乎遮不住肚子的缎面球衣去参加任何运动。而且，我妈妈告诉我关于她打篮球的日子的奇怪事情还不止这些。还有那些规则。埃莉的妈妈打过篮球，但不是我们今天所知的五对五篮球。她打的是六对六爱荷华州女子篮球。当时有三名前锋和三名后卫。作为三名后卫，你们要防守对方的三名前锋。在六对六篮球中，三名前锋只负责进攻。
And the three guards only play defense. No one is allowed to leave their assigned half of the court. I was a guard. So I never shot any baskets. All I did was try to prevent people from shooting baskets. Six on six still uses the full length of a basketball court, but in a different way than five on five. In six player, three forwards from one team,
而三名后卫只负责防守。任何人都不准离开自己被分配的那半场。我是一名后卫。所以我从来没有投过篮。我所做的只是试图阻止别人投篮。六对六仍然使用标准篮球场的全长，但其方式与五对五不同。在六人制中，一支球队的三名前锋，
and three guards from the opposing team play at one end of the court. Meanwhile, their teammates wait at the half court line. So as a guard, one of my big role was to get the ball and get it down to the other half court, so it would be in the hands of our forwards. If the team playing offense makes a basket, the ref throws the ball back to the opposing teams forwards, and now they have a chance to score at the other end of the court. Another way to think about it, it's like two games of three on three with the same ball
和对方球队的三名后卫在球场的一端进行比赛。与此同时，他们的队友在中线等待。因此，作为一名后卫，我的重要职责之一就是拿到球并将其传到另一半场，这样球就会落入我们前锋的手中。如果进攻方进球了，裁判会将球回传给对方球队的前锋，现在他们有机会在球场的另一端得分了。换一种思路来理解，这就像是两场三对三的比赛，共用同一个球，
being tossed back and forth. And then the other thing that was kind of peculiar is you could only dribble the ball twice, and then you had to do something with it. At the same time Ellie's mom was playing six on six, the boys in her high school were playing five on five. Just what was your perception of the rules when you started playing or did you have any? My perception was there were rules for the girls and there were rules for the boys and they were different. And I don't have the memory of feeling like, oh, I wish we could play the boys' rules. It was just kind of like those were our rules. I was 13 when I first found my mom's ear book. And to my teenage ears, the sports sounded confusing
在场上被传来传去。还有一件有点奇特的事情，那就是你只能运两次球，然后你就必须把球传出去或处理掉。在埃莉的妈妈打六对六的同时，她高中的男生们在打五对五。当你开始打球时，你对这些规则有什么看法，或者你当时有什么看法吗？我的看法是，女生有女生的规则，男生有男生的规则，它们是不一样的。我不记得当时有什么“哦，真希望我们也能打男生的规则”这种感觉。就觉得，这些就是我们的规则。我13岁时第一次看到我妈妈的年鉴。在当时的我这个青少年看来，这项运动听起来令人困惑，
and so boring. When the ball is not in your end of the court, do you what, just stand there? What's fun about being a guard if you can never shoot? Not to mention the rules wreaked of sexism. As if Iowans felt they needed to invent a less rigorous version of basketball made just for the girls. But even so, Ellie's mom insisted that girls' six-on-six basketball
而且超级无聊。当球不在你所在的半场时，你是怎么做，就站在那里吗？如果你永远不能投篮，当后卫有什么好玩的？更不用说这些规则充满了性别歧视的意味。就好像爱荷华州的人觉得他们需要为女孩子们发明一个低强度版的篮球。即便如此，埃莉的妈妈坚持认为，六对六女子篮球
was extremely popular, not just at her high school, but all over Iowa. My memories, the stance being filled, like my mother, she was always there. And I think most times she brought her knitting because she would get nervous and then she would be knitting away. At the girls' games, the gyms in Iowa would be packed, and not just with knitting mothers, entire towns would come out to cheer for their team. In fact, it wasn't until my mom left Iowa that she realized this kind of enthusiasm for a girl's sport was rare. That it was regarded as important as boys basketball. I didn't think was unusual.
极其受欢迎，不仅在她自己的高中，而且在整个爱荷华州都是如此。我的记忆中，看台总是座无虚席，就像我母亲一样，她总是会在那里。我想大多数时候她都带着她的织针，因为她会感到紧张，然后她就会不停地织毛衣。在女子比赛中，爱荷华州的体育馆总是挤得水泄不通，不仅有织毛衣的母亲们，整个城镇的人都会倾巢而出为他们的队伍加油。事实上，直到我妈妈离开爱荷华州后，她才意识到这种对女子运动的热情是多么罕见。它被认为和男子篮球一样重要。我不觉得这有什么不寻常的。
I thought that that was just the way the world worked. My whole life, women and girls' sports have been on the defensive. Always put in a position to prove its worth. So I truly could not comprehend what my mom was describing. A girl's sport with weird sexist rules having just as much, if not more success than the boys? So for years, I wrote the sport off. Until, well, now, because the more I looked into it,
我以为世界本来就是这样的。在我的一生中，妇女和女孩的体育运动一直处于防守状态。总是被迫去证明自己的价值。所以我实在无法理解我妈妈所描述的景象：一项有着奇怪的性别歧视规则的女子运动，其成功程度甚至不亚于男子运动，甚至有过之而无不及？因此多年来，我对这项运动不屑一顾。直到现在——因为我深入了解得越多，
the more I realized that my mom wasn't just some six on six fanatic. The game and its rules were popular in Iowa for nearly a century, but the sport would ultimately be abandoned by a federal law designed to end gender discrimination. The story of the rise and fall of Iowa girls' six-on-six starts with the establishment of Women's Basketball in 1892. Women's Basketball is the most fascinating sport because women started playing it almost at exactly the same time men started playing it. And they started playing it at a time when the rules were shifting very quickly.
我就越意识到，我妈妈并非只是什么六对六狂热爱好者。这项运动及其规则在爱荷华州流行了近一个世纪之久，但这项运动最终却被一项旨在消除性别歧视的联邦法律所抛弃。爱荷华州女子六对六篮球兴衰的故事，始于1892年女子篮球运动的创立。女子篮球是一项最迷人的运动，因为女性开始打篮球的时间几乎与男性开始打篮球的时间完全同步。而且她们开始打球时，规则正在发生非常快速的变化。
This is basketball historian Pamela Grundy. She says even back when James Naysmith invented basketball, the rules were still in flux. Dribbling didn't exist at first. That had to get invented. Free throws didn't exist at first. Those had to get invented. Free throws didn't exist at first. Those had to get invented. And what happened with women, the fact that the game was very unshaped
这是篮球历史学家帕梅拉·格伦迪（Pamela Grundy）。她说，甚至早在詹姆斯·奈史密斯（James Naismith）发明篮球的时候，规则还在不断变化中。最初是没有运球这一说的。运球是后来才发明的。最初也没有罚球。罚球也是后来才发明的。最初也没有罚球。罚球也是后来才发明的。而对于女性来说，这项运动在最初阶段
at the beginning meant that they could shape it in a way that was acceptable for women to play. A visit teacher from Smith College named Senda Berenson is credited with being the mother of women's basketball. She learned of Nacemus' new game and met it just miles down the road and thought it would be a good fit for her all-women's gym class, even though team sports for women were practically unheard of in the late 1800s.
非常不成形，这意味着她们可以按照女性适合参与的方式来塑造它。斯密特学院（Smith College）的一位体育老师桑达·伯伦讯（Senda Berenson）被誉为女子篮球之母。她了解到了奈史密斯的新运动，而且就在几英里外的地方见识了它，并认为它非常适合她全女生的体育课，尽管在19世纪末，女性参加团队运动简直闻所未闻。
Basketball was something that allowed women to plan a team to run around, to really be vigorous in a way that traditional women's physical activity didn't allow one to do. So it was something, it was a revelation. They just loved it. You look at the pictures and you listen to what women said about playing basketball back in those early days, and it was just the most amazing thing. Women's colleges promoted exercise for their students, but they also stressed that physical education
篮球让女性能够进行团队合作、四处奔跑，并以传统女性体育活动所不允许的方式进行真正的剧烈运动。所以这绝对是一个全新的启示。她们太喜欢了。看看那些照片，听听女性对早期打篮球的评价，那绝对是最奇妙的事情。女子学院鼓励学生进行锻炼，但她们也强调，体育教育
should not interfere with Christian ideals of womanhood, such as purity, obedience, and domesticity. Even Barenson, a true evangelist for women's physical movement, was deeply concerned that women's basketball never veer outside friendly play. She wanted her rules to favor a civility over competition. Initially, Cindy Baronson made rules that made the women's game a little bit different. Made rules that made the game seem a little more sedate. Have a little less physical contact.
不应该干扰基督教关于女性特质的理想，比如纯洁、顺从和贤惠。甚至连伯伦讯这位女性身体运动的真正布道者，也深感担忧，生怕女子篮球偏离了友谊第一的比赛性质。她希望她的规则倾向于文明礼貌，而不是竞争。最初，辛迪·巴伦森（Cindy Baronson，注：应为 Senda Berenson 的误读或化名）制定了一些规则，让女子比赛变得有些不同。制定了让比赛看起来更温和的规则。减少了一点身体接触。
In this early iteration of women's basketball, the court was divided into three zones, nine players on each team passing the ball from zone to zone attempting to score a basket. In this early iteration of women's basketball, the court was divided into three zones, nine players on each team passing the ball from zone to zone attempting to score a basket. There was no grabbing at the ball, no more than three dribbles, and the winning team had to host a dinner for the defeated team. Barenson continued to refine the rules at the turn of the century, but by then women's basketball had already spread throughout the country. And one of the places it found a foothold was rural Iowa.
在这个早期版本的女子篮球中，球场被划分为三个区域，每支球队有九名球员，将球从一个区域传到另一个区域，试图投篮得分。在这个早期版本的女子篮球中，球场被划分为三个区域，每支球队有九名球员，将球从一个区域传到另一个区域，试图投篮得分。场上不允许抢球，运球不得超过三次，并且获胜的球队必须为战败的球队举办晚宴。世纪之交时，伯伦讯继续完善规则，但到那时，女子篮球已经传遍了全国。它扎根的地方之一就是爱荷华州的农村地区。
Basketball was a good fit for rural Iowa. It needed limited equipment and could be played indoors in the winter. It was an easy activity for these tiny towns to rally around. Little towns of 200, 300 people, they played basketball. Not so in the cities, see cities in Iowa did not play any kind of sports until after mid-century. This is Max McElwain, an academic former sports reporter and native Iowan.
篮球非常适合爱荷华州的农村地区。它只需要有限的设备，并且可以在冬天的室内进行。对于这些小城镇来说，这是一项很容易凝聚人心的活动。两三百人的小城镇也在打篮球。城市里可不是这样，你看，爱荷华州的城市直到世纪中叶以后才开展任何体育运动。这是马克斯·麦克尔温（Max McElwain），一位学者、前体育记者兼爱荷华州本地人。
Max told me that while people in the city were debating whether sports were appropriate for girls, that just wasn't a concern in small town Iowa. They were likely farm girls, they were likely having to do all sorts of physical chores on their farms, and there wasn't that sort of bifurcation between being an athlete and being feminine. In the first few decades of Iowa Girls Basketball,
马克斯告诉我，当城里的人们还在争论体育运动是否适合女孩时，这在爱荷华州的小镇根本不是个问题。她们很可能是农场女孩，她们可能不得不在农场里做各种体力农活，而且在“成为一名运动员”和“保持女性气质”之间并没有那种截然的分裂。在爱荷华州女子篮球的头几十年里，
the rules could differ from county to county. Some were six players, some eight were nine. All the iterations were inspired by sendabarinsons to date rules, but with one big exception. Iowans wanted their teams to win. They wanted the girls to compete just like the boys. In 1920, the Des Moines Register, the largest newspaper in the state, sponsored the first Iowa Girls High School basketball tournament. And despite the event being hosted in the big city, only teams from tiny rural towns were invited. Other states also launched similar tournaments around this time.
规则可能因县而异。有些是六人制，有些是八人制或九人制。所有的迭代都受到桑达·伯伦讯温和规则的启发，但有一个巨大的例外。爱荷华州人希望他们的球队赢球。他们希望女孩们像男孩一样去竞争。1920年，《得梅因纪事报》（Des Moines Register，该州最大的报纸）赞助了第一届爱荷华州高中女子篮球锦标赛。尽管这项赛事是在大城市举办的，但只有来自偏远小城镇的球队受邀参加。其他州也在这前后推出了类似的锦标赛。
College educated PE teachers in the mold of Senda Berencine saw this increase in girls' competition, and they were alarmed. To them, girls basketball was supposed to be fun and active, but never motivated by winning and certainly not played in front of audiences. They looked around at the competition in men's sports and saw these intense rivalries and violence and wanted something different for women. So as a result, at the same time basketball was gaining popularity around the country, there was a major backlash.
受过大学教育、带有桑达·伯伦讯风格的体育老师们看到女孩们竞争的增加，感到十分惊慌。在他们看来，女子篮球本该是有趣且充满活力的，但绝不能由获胜的渴望来驱动，更不能在观众面前比赛。他们环顾男子体育界，看到了那种激烈的竞争和暴力，希望为女性寻找一些不同的东西。因此，就在篮球在全国各地越来越受欢迎的同时，也引发了强烈的反对。
Accounter movement of people like Berencine that lobbied school administrators and athletic organizers to keep competition out of girls' sports. There start to be conflict between these physical educators and these sort of local communities who started these tournaments and physical educators really push to eliminate girls' tournaments and to tamp down competition for girls. And so you'll have these statewide battles over this. And in many cases the people pushing to end competition for girls, they win. So there are states where the girls' state tournaments and girls' competition general just gets eliminated.
像伯伦讯这样的人发起了一场反运动，游说学校管理者和体育组织者将竞争排除在女子运动之外。这些体育教育者与那些发起这些锦标赛的当地社区之间开始出现冲突，体育教育者极力推动取消女子锦标赛，并压制女孩们的竞争。因此，你会看到关于此事的全州范围内的争论。在许多情况下，那些推动终结女孩竞争的人赢了。因此，有些州的女子州锦标赛以及普遍的女子比赛直接被取消了。
Physical educators influence the legislatures to say, no, we will not have this. We'll have a voice tournament. We're not going to have a girls tournament. And so in 1925, there was this big meeting in Iowa with the high school administrators about ending girls basketball. Cities like Des Moines were easily persuaded to shut down their programs. But farm country was not happening. I was small towns were fiercely protective of girls basketball. They
体育教育工作者影响了立法机关，说：“不，我们不能这样。我们将举办男子锦标赛。我们不会举办女子锦标赛。”因此，在1925年，爱荷华州召开了一次关于终结女子篮球的高中管理者的大型会议。像得梅因这样的城市很容易就被说服关闭了他们的项目。但农场乡村可不答应。爱荷华州的小城镇极其坚决地捍卫女子篮球。他们
resented this kind of outside interference. So in that big meeting that decided the fate of the sport, a group of educators and coaches descended. It's hard to do much research on this without coming across a famous quote from the meeting. Gentlemen, if you attempt to do away with girls basketball in Iowa, you'll be standing in the center of the track when the train runs you over. So you have this group of rebels who really support girls basketball and they say, you know, we're just not going to stand that. We will leave, and we're gonna start our own association, and we're gonna have our own tournament.
痛恨这种外部干涉。因此，在决定该运动命运的那场大型会议上，一群教育家和教练涌入会场。要对这段历史进行深入研究，很难绕过会议上的一句名言：“先生们，如果你们企图取消爱荷华州的女子篮球，当火车碾过你们时，你们就只能站在铁轨的正中央。”所以，你有一群坚决支持女子篮球的叛逆者，他们说：“你知道的，我们绝不忍气吞声。我们要离开，我们要创办自己的协会，我们要举办自己的锦标赛。”
That's what happens, and that's the beginning of the real, you know, flowering of Iowa High School Girls Basketball, is when they win a battle that supporters of Girls Basketball in many, many, many states across the country lose. The rebels who supported Girls Basketball in many, many, many states across the country lose. The rebels who supported Girls Basketball started the first Girls Athletic Union in the country. It was run by a group of men who relaunched the state tournament. And by 1934, the union codified a set of rules for the girls' game.
事情就是这样发生的，这也正是爱荷华州高中女子篮球真正大放异彩的开端——他们赢得了这场在全国许多、许多、许多州的女子篮球支持者们所输掉的战役。支持女子篮球的叛逆者们创办了全国第一个女子田径联合会。它由一群男性运营，他们重新举办了全州锦标赛。到1934年，该联合会为女子比赛制定了一套成文规则。
The six-on-six rules Ellie's mom grew up with. Only forwards shoot. Guards only play defense, and everyone has to stay on their assigned half of the court. There were also no tie-ups outside the key, which basically means no wrestling for the ball except under the basket. And this all might make the game sound stilted, but when I finally watched some of the archives, I was like, damn, this is fun. If you see the game, I mean, it's very fast.
也就是埃莉的妈妈在其中长大的六对六规则。只有前锋投篮。后卫只负责防守，每个人都必须呆在自己被分配的那半场。罚球区外也不允许扭打，这基本上意味着除了篮下之外，不允许为争夺球权而进行摔跤。这一切听起来可能会让比赛显得有些生硬呆板，但当我最终观看了一些历史资料时，我想：天哪，这太有趣了。如果你看比赛，我是说，它非常快。
It's very rhythmic. It's quite impressive. It does have a nice flow. Bounce bounce pass, bounce bounce shoot. The restrictions actually have a strange way of encouraging movement and opening up space. Man, the good high school players could learn how to get from half court to the basket in two dribbles. This is Lisa Bluder. Today, she's head coach of the women's basketball team at the University of Iowa, a top 25 program in the whole country, and she got her start playing high school six on six. Lisa says the rules helped generate a lot of offense.
非常有节奏感。相当令人印象深刻。它确实有一种很好的流畅感。运、运、传，运、运、投。这些限制实际上以一种奇妙的方式鼓励了跑动并开辟了空间。天哪，优秀的高中球员可以学会如何在两次运球之内从半场冲到篮下。这是丽莎·布吕德尔（Lisa Bluder）。如今，她是爱荷华大学女子篮球队的主教练，该队是全国前25名的强队，而她的篮球生涯正是从高中六对六开始起步的。丽莎说，这些规则有助于产生大量的进攻。
The floor was so spread out, you know, with only six players instead of 10 players being around the basket. In a regular five on five game, as many as 10 players can be in one half the court at the same time. That makes it harder to find space to get off a clean shot or a lab. But in six on six, there are fewer defenders and fewer shooters playing against each other. That gives offensive minded players more chances to score, more points under more favorable conditions. I think I scored 105 in a game. This is Jan Jensen, Lisa's associate coach at the University of Iowa who also played 6
球场空间拉得非常开，你知道的，因为篮下只有6名球员而不是10名球员。在一场标准的五对五比赛中，多达10名球员可以同时挤在半场。这使得人们更难找到空间来完成一次干净的投篮或上篮。但在六对六中，防守球员更少，互相交手的射手也更少。这给进攻型球员提供了更多得分的机会，在更有利的条件下获得更多的分数。我想我在一场比赛中得了 105 分。这是简·詹森（Jan Jensen），丽莎在爱荷华大学的副教练，她当年在高中也打过6
on 6 back in her high school. She was one of the great offensive stars of her era. I averaged I think 66 points a game. And all my friends were like, how did you score that many points? And you weren't a ball hog. And I said, I can't explain it to you. It's just kind of how the 6 on 6 was. That was my role.
对6。她是她那个时代伟大的进攻球星之一。我记得我场均能得 66 分。我所有的朋友都问：“你是怎么得到那么多分的？你又不是个独行侠。”我说：“我无法向你们解释。这就是6对6的常态。这就是我的角色。”
These high scoring affairs were the stuff of legend. Even Jans Jensen's grandmother, who also played back in the 1920s, earned herself an all-time nickname. She was Dorcas Anderson, Dorcas' a biblical name, but they nicknamed her Loddy because she scored a lot of points. When I visited Jan, I got to see the 100-year-old leather basketball her grandmother used. When I touched the ball, it just makes me feel a little bit closer. It's just this kind of a history that we shared. One of the reasons this form of girls basketball
这些高比分的对决堪称传奇。甚至简·詹森的祖母——她也在20世纪20年代打过球——还为自己赢得了一个流传至今的绰号。她叫多卡斯·安德森（Dorcas Anderson），多卡斯是一个圣经里的名字，但他们给她起了个绰号叫“洛迪”（Loddy），因为她得了超级多的分数。我去拜访简时，看到了她祖母用过的那颗有100年历史的皮革篮球。当我触摸到这颗球时，它让我感觉离那段历史更近了一些。这就是我们共同分享的历史。这种女子篮球之所以
worked so well for these small towns is that the game supported more opportunities for specialization. If you were sturdy, you could play guard. If you were a natural shooter, you could play forward. You didn't have to be talented in all the different parts of the game. You could simply play offense or defense. I have a real soft spot for the guards. They didn't get the glory of setting points records, but mostly I'm fond of them because I totally would have been a guard. This was really solidified for me when I talked to Angie Looney who played in the 1970s. I was a forward until my sister came up
对这些小城镇如此奏效的原因之一，在于这项运动支持了更多专业化的发展。如果你身体结实，你可以打后卫。如果你天生是个神射手，你可以打前锋。你不必在比赛的所有不同部分都才华横溢。你只需专心进攻或防守。我对后卫有着一种由衷的喜爱。他们没有创造得分纪录的荣耀，但我主要喜欢他们，是因为我绝对会去当后卫。当我与在20世纪70年代打过球的安吉·洛尼（Angie Looney）交谈时，这种感觉对我来说更加坚定了。我原本是个前锋，直到我妹妹升上高一，
and she was a freshman and she took my spot. And so I went to the guard and it's like, well, why didn't I do this earlier? Because it was way more fun because it was way more physical, took the pressure off, I didn't have to score, and could just really go out and just be tough and rough and anticipate. Anticipation is such an important skill in sports,
她抢了我的位置。于是我改打后卫，当时我就想：“天哪，我为什么不早点这么做？”因为这好玩多了，因为身体对抗性更强，压力也小了，我不用去得分，可以真正地走上场去，表现得强硬、凶猛，并去预判。预判是体育运动中一项非常重要的技能，
and it has nothing to do with your body type. It's all about how you strategize for a game. And by the way, in case you haven't already noticed, in the process of reporting this story, six on six totally won me over. I'm convinced that in another life, I would have been in these small town gyms right alongside the women I spoke to. I remember playing at Deep River Millersburg, a little town. This is Emily Hoppy. She's actually from my mom's town, Amanda Iowa.
它与你的体型毫无关系。这完全取决于你如何为一场比赛制定策略。顺便说一句，如果你还没注意到的话，在报道这个故事的过程中，六对六完全赢得了我的心。我坚信，在另一种人生里，我也会和那些我采访过的女性一样，身处这些小城镇的体育馆里。我记得曾在深河米勒斯堡（Deep River Millersburg）这个小镇打过球。这是埃米莉·霍皮（Emily Hoppy）。她其实就来自我妈妈的家乡——爱荷华州阿曼达。
I asked Emily to describe the most memorable, crammed gym she played in. That gym was so small that the baseline was actually the wall. And then the whole other side was where the fan sat. And it was possible on an inbound throw to stand there and have people touch you. And there might be 300 people because people really came to those games. Oh my gosh.
我请埃米莉描述她打过的那座最难忘、最拥挤的体育馆。那座体育馆太小了，底线实际上就是墙壁。然后另一边则是球迷坐的地方。在发边线球时，你甚至可以站在那里，让别人碰到你。现场可能会有300人，因为人们是真的会来看比赛的。哦，天哪。
That was the social thing to do. For many schools, the girls team wasn't just some warm up act before the boys game. They were the show. Here's Max McEwan. It just went without saying that the basketball ball that you were going to see in the most exciting was the girls. That's just, and it was no joke that people sometimes left after girls games. And just a quick footnote here, but I feel like it's worth mentioning that Iowa wasn't
那是当地人社交的绝佳去处。对许多学校来说，女子球队绝不仅仅是男子比赛前的暖场节目。她们才是整场的主角。这是马克斯·麦克尔温。不言而喻，你去看的最精彩、最刺激的篮球比赛绝对是女子比赛。就是这样，人们有时在看完女子比赛后就直接离开，这可不是开玩笑的。这里顺便提一个小插曲，我觉得值得一提的是，爱荷华州并不是
the only place with this hidden history of playing girls basketball. Working women played in the Southern textile mill league, a bunch of Catholic schools fielded teams, so did many black high schools and colleges. Even Texas and Oklahoma had a history of playing 6 on 6. But nowhere had a rich, unbroken tradition of competitive girls basketball like Iowa. All of the games in these small town gyms mattered because everyone wanted to qualify for the state tournament. A tournament which has drawn a total of close to 75,000 fans for its five day run.
唯一一个拥有这种隐藏的女子篮球历史的地方。职业女性曾在南方纺织厂联盟打过球，许多天主教学校组建了球队，许多黑人高中和大学也是如此。甚至得克萨斯州和俄克拉荷马州也有打六对六的历史。但没有任何地方能像爱荷华州那样，拥有如此丰富、从未中断过的女子竞技篮球传统。所有这些小镇体育馆里的比赛都至关重要，因为每个人都想获得参加州锦标赛的资格。这项为期五天的赛事总共吸引了近 7.5 万名球迷。
Small wonder that Iowa has earned for itself the title of Queen State of Girl's High School Basketball. We made it one game from state, but it still bothers me that I never made it to the state tournament. I mean, that was just like a dream. If you made it to the state tournament, it was like, wow, you hit the pinnacle.
难怪爱荷华州为自己赢得了“高中女子篮球女王州”的称号。我们离打进州锦标赛只差一场比赛，但没能进入州锦标赛依然让我感到遗憾。我的意思是，那简直就像是一个梦想。如果你打进了州锦标赛，那就如同：哇，你达到了巅峰。
At the state tournament, stars of the game were born and legends were honored. Everyone I spoke to had extremely fond memories of this big event in Des Moines, and they all attended games in the era of E. Wayne Cooley. Cooley was, as I described, and was sort of the wringling brother's sort of character. He was a great showman,
在州锦标赛上，这项运动的巨星们诞生了，传奇人物也受到了表彰。我采访过的每个人对得梅因的这场盛事都怀有极其美好的回忆，而且他们都曾出席过 E·韦恩·库利（E. Wayne Cooley）时期的比赛。正如我所描述的，库利有点像玲玲马戏团（Ringling Brothers）那种风格的人物。他是个伟大的表演大师，
and he realized that using television and other public relations tools, he could make the state basketball tournament into something unparalleled, which he did. Cooley was hired by the Iowa girls athletic union in 1954 and played a huge role expanding the television broadcast of the tournament. By the late 1960s, the state finals were drawing five million viewers from nine states. He aimed to transform the tournament. By the late 1960s, the state finals were drawing five million viewers from nine states. He aimed to transform the tournament into a spectacle not only for viewers, but for attendees. There would be almost 200,000 people there over the course of a week, just incredible and heard of. It was the old Vets Auditorium. Vets Auditorium
他意识到，通过电视和其他公共关系工具，他可以将州篮球锦标赛变成一项无与伦比的盛事，而他也确实做到了。库利于 1954 年被爱荷华州女子田径联合会雇用，在扩大该锦标赛的电视转播方面发挥了巨大作用。到 20 世纪 60 年代末，州决赛吸引了来自 9 个州的 500 万观众。他旨在将这场锦标赛。到 20 世纪 60 年代末，州决赛吸引了来自 9 个州的 500 万观众。他旨在将这场锦标赛不仅打造成观众的视觉盛宴，也打造成现场参与者的狂欢。在一周的时间里，现场将会有将近 20 万人，简直不可思议、闻所未闻。那是老退伍军人礼堂（Vets Auditorium）。退伍军人礼堂
was the hottest ticket. I mean, I would see the same people at the state tournament always. They had the same state tournament tickets for 40, 50 years. There were fancy programs, merging bands, and Koolie even started a tradition. Everybody remembers. Now, ladies and gentlemen, the cleanest show in town. There'd be a whole group of boys, and they would sweep the floor with these broad, janitorial bruises in sync.
是一票难求的热门去处。我的意思是，我总能在州锦标赛上看到同一批人。他们连续 40、50 年买的都是同一个州锦标赛座位。那里有精美的场刊、行进乐队，库利甚至还发起了一个传统，
And they all dressed alike. One year, I remember they were all wearing tuxedos. And the boys, I was told, volunteered and kind of I'd to do this. What a concept. They're sweeping the floor and making it pristine for women. I mean, isn't that a big shift? Koolie didn't only pay attention to the sport during the big tournament. He was committed to the sports
每个人都记忆犹新。现在，女士们先生们，城里最干净的表演。会有一大群男孩，他们手里拿着这种宽大的、清洁工用的扫帚，动作整齐划一地清扫地板。他们都穿着一样的衣服。我记得有一年，他们都穿着燕尾服。我听说，这些男孩都是自愿且很乐意这么做的。多么有创意的概念。他们正在清扫地板，为女性让场地保持一尘不染。我的意思是，这难道不是一个巨大的转变吗？库利不仅在大型锦标赛期间关注这项运动。他致力于这项运动的
maintenance and integrity year-round. That sort of stewardship helped usher in a golden era for girls basketball in Iowa. But here's the thing about Kool-E. He was a showman, and so he was obsessed with image. And he held some regressive ideas about what kind of girls get to represent the sport. When Kool-E was first elected to lead the union, he instituted a rule that prohibited girls who were married or had children from playing high school basketball.
全年维护和保持其纯洁性。这种管理帮助爱荷华州迎来了女子篮球的黄金时代。但关于库利，有一点是这样的：他是一个表演大师，因此他痴迷于形象。对于什么样的女孩才能代表这项运动，他抱有一些退步的思想。当库利首次当选领导该联合会时，他制定了一项规则，禁止已婚或育有孩子的女孩打高中篮球。
For him, quote, husbands and homes were the first obligation of wives. In other words, no teen moms. It actually took a lawsuit in 1971 to persuade Coulee and the Union to repeal the sexist rule. And one short year later, a landmark piece of legislation would change Kool-E's grip over the sport and the very existence of sex on sex. Title IX comes in which says that educational institutions must provide equal opportunity for women and everything.
对他而言，“丈夫和家庭是妻子们的第一义务”。换句话说，不欢迎未成年妈妈。直到 1971 年的一起诉讼，才最终说服了库利和联合会废除这项性别歧视的规则。短短一年后，一项具有里程碑意义的立法将改变库利对这项运动的掌控力，以及六对六存在的根基。第九条（Title IX）出台了，它规定教育机构必须在所有方面为女性提供平等的机会。
Title IX is a federal civil rights law passed in 1972. It prohibits discrimination on the basis of sex in any educational program or activity that receives federal financial assistance. It was motivated by explicit discrimination in colleges, such as women being barred from certain programs and courses, as well as the mistreatment of female faculty members. People weren't even thinking of sports
《第九条》是一项于 1972 年通过的联邦民权法。它禁止在任何接受联邦财政援助的教育计划或活动中基于性别的歧视。它的出台是由大学中明显的歧视行为引发的，例如女性被禁止参加某些课程和项目，以及对女性教职员工的虐待。人们甚至都没有想到体育运动
when Title IX was passed because the disparity was so taken for granted. Regardless, it ended up being a big win for women and girls sports across the country. And initially, that was the case for Iowa too. The law encouraged Iowa cities to finally support competitive girls basketball after giving it up in the 1920s.
当《第九条》通过时，因为这种巨大的差距当时被认为是理所当然的。无论如何，它最终成为了全国妇女和女孩体育运动的一场巨大胜利。最初，爱荷华州也是如此。这项法律鼓励爱荷华州的城市在 20 世纪 20 年代放弃女子篮球后，终于重新开始支持竞技女子篮球。
That, I think, is part of the story that doesn't get very much attention, but is the last chapter before 6 on 6 stopped being 6 on 6. Deb Rettman attended high school in Cedar Rapids in the early 70s. She grew up in Iowa watching the state tournament on TV, but her school didn't have a girls' basketball program. Fortunately for her, the momentum of Title IX and the women's movement finally brought six on six to her city. What she remembers most is driving out into farm country to play against some of the teams
我认为，这是那段历史中不太受关注的一部分，但却是六对六不再是六对六之前的最后一个篇章。黛布·雷特曼（Deb Rettman）于 70 年代初在锡达拉皮兹（Cedar Rapids）上高中。她在爱荷华州长大，在电视上观看州锦标赛，但她的学校没有女子篮球队。幸运的是，《第九条》和妇女运动的势头最终将六对六带到了她的城市。她记忆最深刻的是驱车前往农场乡村去和一些球队比赛，
she grew up admiring. I will never forget riding the bus all the way up to North East Goose Lake. And they just pounded us, of course. Just pounded us in the people in the stands. We're cheering them on. And I'm what's taking gosh, how cool is this? I mean, we're totally losing. But what those small schools and those women did was teach us.
那些球队是她从小就很崇拜的。我永远不会忘记坐着大巴一直开到东北部的鹅湖（Goose Lake）。当然，他们把我们痛击了一顿。看台的人们把我们痛击了一顿，还在为他们加油。我当时心里想：天哪，这太酷了吧？我的意思是，我们彻底输了。但那些小学校和那些女性所做的事情，是给我们上了生动的一课。
I love this, getting creamed, but still being excited to be a part of things. But while Deb was enjoying her introduction to 6 on 6, the standard basketball game in the rest of the country, and particularly at the collegiate level, was heading in the other direction, towards 5-on-5. Suddenly, if you're a school administrator in Iowa with a girls basketball program, you have to decide what rules to use. Six on six, the legacy sport of the state, the sport that supported generations of girls
我太喜欢这种感觉了，虽然被打得落花流水，但依然为能成为其中一部分而感到兴奋。但正当黛布享受她对六对六的初体验时，全国其他地方的标准篮球比赛、尤其是在大学水平上，却朝着另一个方向发展——朝着五对五迈进。突然之间，如果你是爱荷华州一所拥有女子篮球队的学校管理者，你必须决定使用什么规则。是六对六——该州的传统体育运动、曾支持爱荷华州几代女孩的运动，
in Iowa, or 5-on-5, a sport that now represents a quality between men and women. All over the country, high schools were choosing five on five because that's what the colleges had chosen to play, and college sports means opportunities for college scholarships. Here's Pamela Grundy. That's when in Iowa, it just becomes more difficult because if you're a young woman and you would like a basketball scholarship to college or you would like to play basketball in college or maybe you'd like to go play basketball in the Olympics someday because of course in 1976 you get the first women's Olympic basketball team but you've grown up playing a very different game.
还是五对五——一项现在代表着男女平等的运动。全国各地的高中都在选择五对五，因为那是大学选择打的规则，而大学体育意味着大学奖学金的机会。这是帕梅拉·格伦迪。这就是爱荷华州的情况变得更具挑战性的时候，因为如果你是一名年轻女性，你想要一份大学篮球奖学金，或者你想在大学里打篮球，或者也许你希望有一天能去打奥运会篮球——因为当然，在 1976 年，你迎来了第一支女子奥运篮球队——但你从小到大玩的是一种截然不同的游戏。
You can't just switch easily from one to the other. And so you're at a tremendous disadvantage. But the allure of playing college ball didn't carry the same weight in rural Iowa, in part because they already had a prestigious sport. Six player had this huge infrastructure behind it. And besides, if you were good enough, some six on six girls were getting recruited to play five on five for colleges anyway. Including Lisa Bluder,
你不能轻而易举地从一种切换到另一种。所以你处于极大的劣势。但打大学篮球的诱惑在爱荷华州农村并没有那么大的分量，部分原因是因为他们已经有了一项声望极高的运动。六人制背后有着巨大的基础设施支持。此外，如果你足够优秀，有些六对六的女孩无论如何都会被招募去大学打五对五。其中包括丽莎·布吕德尔，
the women's head coach at the University of Iowa. I remember on the forum when they asked you what position you played, I was like, I'm not sure. I didn't really know what the five on five game, I knew I was a forward in high school in the 6 on 6 game, so I wrote down forward. I had been a good high school player and I got recruited. I was sort of surprised by that because I played 6 on 6 and they would have no idea whether I could really transition well. This is Ruth Byerhelm. She's from Minneapolis, a small town that qualified for the state tournament more times than any other.
爱荷华大学女子篮球队的主教练。我记得在表格上问你打什么位置时，我当时想：我不确定。我真的不知道五对五的比赛是怎么样的，我只知道我在六对六的高中比赛中是个前锋，所以我写下了前锋。我曾是一名优秀的高中球员，我也被招募了。我对此有点惊讶，因为我打的是六对六，他们根本不知道我是否能很好地过渡。这是露丝·拜尔海姆（Ruth Byerhelm）。她来自明尼阿波利斯（Minneapolis），这是一个打进州锦标赛次数比其他任何地方都多的小镇。
Ruth was able to transition into five-player, but there was one big problem. I did not enjoy five-on-five basketball at all. So tell me about that. There's too many damn people in the way. You know what I mean? And five-on-five, there's just too many. way. You know what I mean? And five on five, there's just too many. Title IX forced the birth of tons of women's basketball programs, but it didn't necessarily
露丝能够过渡到五人制，但有一个巨大的问题。我一点也不喜欢五对五篮球。那么跟我讲讲这个。中间有太多该死的人挡着。你知道我的意思吗？在五对五中，人实在太多了。挡着。你知道我的意思吗？在五对五中，人实在太多了。《第九条》催生了大量女子篮球项目的诞生，但这并不意味着
mean that the women's game was treated with the same weight as the men's. Ruth, for her part, was shocked at the drop in status. The university was terrible. I mean, just as an example, the women's team got one pair of shoes at the beginning of the year. That's it. The men's team, they could have unlimited numbers of shoes they wanted. And so a lot of them who thought they were big stars
女子比赛能受到与男子比赛同等的对待。就露丝而言，她对地位的落差感到震惊。这所大学太糟糕了。我的意思是，仅举个例子，女队在年初只发了一双鞋。就这样。而男队呢，他们想要多少双鞋就可以有多少双。所以其中许多自认为是超级巨星的人
would have these games and then they would take their shoes off at the end of the game and give it to some kid of fan. You know, it was like, dude, you squirt two points and had a rebound. Nobody wants your shoes. And for Jan Jensen, she noticed the drop in attendance. It wasn't until I went to college that I understood the necessity of Title IX. In high school, I mean, the crowds were standing room only for our girls' games. Ruth Jan and Lisa were able to transition to five players,
打完比赛后，他们会在比赛结束时脱下鞋子，送给某个年轻球迷。你知道的，这就像是：老兄，你得了两分，抢了一个篮板。没人想要你的鞋。而对于简·詹森来说，她注意到了现场观众人数的下降。直到我上大学后，我才真正理解了《第九条》的必要性。在高中时，我的意思是，我们的女子比赛总是座无虚席。露丝、简和丽莎都成功过渡到了五人制，
but many top-level high school six-on-six players and their families wanted to eliminate any roadblocks on the path to these new athletic scholarships. So in 1983, a lawsuit was filed arguing that Iowa's six-on-six basketball violated the equal protection clause of the U.S. Constitution. Iowa girls basketball was under a ton of pressure to assimilate. In a last-ditch effort to preserve 6-on-6, the union allowed schools to choose whether they play five player or six player. Iowa's small towns held onto their game for as long as they could before it
但许多顶级的高中六对六球员及其家庭希望清除通往这些新体育奖学金道路上的任何绊脚石。因此，在 1983 年，有人提起诉讼，称爱荷华州的六对六篮球违反了美国宪法中的平等保护条款。爱荷华州女子篮球承受了巨大的同化压力。为了挽救六对六，联合会在做最后一搏时，允许学校在五人制或六人制之间进行选择。爱荷华州的小城镇尽可能长时间地坚守着他们的运动，直到它
simply became too complicated. player. Iowa's small towns held onto their game for as long as they could before it simply became too complicated. People saw the writing on the wall. Everybody knew that a sort of way of life was over. The last six on six state tournament was held in 1993. It's the shot. It'll not know good. Two seconds, one second. And that will be the buzzer and the ball game. I just think that 6 on 6 was so different that anybody who got to play it has an incredible sense of pride. You know, now that it's been over for a couple of decades or whatever, I think those of us that got to play it were so even more grateful.
变得实在太复杂了。人们看到了大势所趋。每个人都知道，那种生活方式已经结束了。最后一届六对六州锦标赛于 1993 年举行。这是投篮。没进。两秒，一秒。比赛结束的蜂鸣器将随之响起。我只是觉得六对六是如此与众不同，以至于任何有幸打过它的人都有一种无与伦比的自豪感。你知道的，现在这项运动已经结束了几十年，我想我们这些打过它的人感到更加感激。
Because it was unique and we look back on it and I just feel like it was a really special era. For a long time, I didn't take 6 on 6 seriously. And what it really boils down to is that I didn't think it was real basketball. Real basketball, real sports are what the boys play. I knew this because when I was little, I played pickup baseball and football with the neighborhood boys, but never in organized leagues because there were none for girls. This early experience made it really easy for me to assume that feminism is just about getting what the boys get. Learning about 6 on 6 showed me how contrived these sports hierarchies really are.
因为它独一无二，每当回想起来，我都觉得那是一个非常特别的时代。很长一段时间里，我都没有认真对待过六对六。归根结底，是因为我当时觉得那不是真正的篮球。真正的篮球、真正的运动是男孩子玩的。我之所以知道这一点，是因为我很小的时候，经常和邻居男孩们一起打野球和橄榄球，但从来没有加入过有组织的联赛，因为当时根本没有女子的联赛。这段早期的经历让我非常轻易地以为，女权主义就是去得到男孩子所拥有的东西。了解了六对六之后，我才发现这些体育等级制度是多么的刻意和虚构。
Small town Iowa girls didn't yearn to play the boys rules because they already had a culture where girls basketball was valued. Places like where my mom grew up saw the potential in girls basketball and chose to care about it, chose to put money and maintenance into it. They didn't expect it to erupt from the soil fully formed. Our sports culture, how inclusive it is, how prestigious is a collective choice. A choice that Iowa reminded me is ours to make. After the break, the stars of 6 on 6 and the game of the century. All right, we're back with Ellie Gordon Marshall, and I hear you have something more to tell us about Iowa 6 on 6.
爱荷华州小镇的女孩们并不渴望去打男生的规则，因为她们已经拥有了一种重视女子篮球的文化。像我妈妈长大的那些地方，看到了女子篮球的潜力并选择去关爱它，选择投入资金和维护。它们并不期望这项运动能从土壤中自然而然地完美生长出来。我们的体育文化，它的包容性有多强、声望有多高，是一个集体选择。爱荷华州提醒我们，这个选择权掌握在我们手中。休息过后，我们将迎来六对六的明星们以及世纪大战。好了，我们回来了，和埃莉·戈登·马歇尔在一起，我听说你还有更多关于爱荷华州六对六的事情要告诉我们。
Yes, I fear there will be an uprising if I don't at least highlight some of the superstars of the game. Well, I mean, we met one of them during the course, the story, Jan Jensen, who scored it was like 105 points during a game. Yes, yes, she did. And Roman, I hope you don't mind if I take a moment to point out something kind of frivolous, but a bunch of the six on six legends I'm about to go through have the coolest, a literative name. Okay, tell me more. So we have our pal Jen Jensen, of course. But there's also Lynn Lorenzen. She was the all-time leading scorer in the whole state. And there is Heather headings. If you follow girls basketball at all, um, people can't in new my name.
是的，我担心如果不至少强调一下这项运动的一些超级巨星，就会引发暴动。嗯，我的意思是，我们在课程、故事中遇到了其中一位，简·詹森（Jan Jensen），她在比赛中得了大约 105 分。是的，是的，她确实得了。罗曼，我希望你介意我花点时间指出一些有点无聊的事情，但我将要回顾的许多六人制传奇人物都有最酷的、押韵的名字。好吧，多告诉我一些。所以我们有我们的朋友简·詹森，当然。但还有琳·洛伦森（Lynn Lorenzen）。她是整个州历史上的头号得分手。还有希瑟·海丁斯（Heather Headings）。如果你稍微关注一下女子篮球，嗯，人们会记住我的名字。
Boxed through five feet six. Heather headings. She's the tournament queen. So I actually got to speak with Heather who played in Mediapolis, that dynasty basketball town I mentioned in the piece, and Heather was a forward on the Mediapolis team that won the state tournament in 1973. I mean, while we're on the subject of names, Mediapolis is a top tier small town name. I mean, that is fantastic. I know, it's so good. It sounds like it's from the Phantom toll booth, you know, a digital top list, dictionopolis. Anyway, after her playing days, Heather went on to be a dentist,
身高五英尺六英寸的希瑟·海丁斯。她是锦标赛女王。所以我实际上和希瑟交谈过，她在梅迪亚波利斯（Mediapolis）打过球，那是我在文章中提到的那个篮球王朝小镇，希瑟是 1973 年赢得州锦标赛的梅迪亚波利斯队的锋线球员。我的意思是，既然我们在讨论名字，梅迪亚波利斯是一个顶级的小镇名字。我的意思是，这太棒了。我知道，这太棒了。听起来像是出自《幻影车票亭》，你知道的，一个数字字典名称“词典opolis”。无论如何，在她的球员生涯结束后，希瑟成为了一名牙医，
and she told me this funny story about meeting a patient's daughter who actually named her child after her. And her name was Heather Harris. I wanted a musical name like Heather Hedons and so we named her Heather Harris. Oh my God. You can hear how excited I am by this interview. And now whenever I'm around someone who's looking for a new name, for like a pet or like a car or something, I always suggest a famous six on six player. And very recently, I just convinced my friend in the
她跟我讲了一个有趣的故事，关于她遇到一个病人的女儿，那个女儿居然用她的名字给自己的孩子命名。她的名字叫希瑟·哈里斯（Heather Harris）。我想要一个像希瑟·海丁斯那样有音乐感的名，所以我们给她取名叫希瑟·哈里斯。噢，天哪。你可以听到我对这次采访是多么兴奋。现在，每当我身边有人在寻找新名字时，比如给宠物或汽车什么的，我总是会推荐一个著名的六人制球员。就在最近，我刚刚说服了我在
Yukon to name her porcupine puppet Deb Cotes. Okay. So who's Deb Cotes? So Deb Cotes, she actually played with Heather head ins probably the most outstanding player we'd ever had in my time was Deb Cotes. For a straight field goals for amazing Debbie Cotes. She's a tournament scoring leader, 173 points in three games so far. was Deb Cotes. So something we didn't get to talk about in the piece was how much of a role newspapers like the Des Moines register played and supporting the game. Girls grew up
育空地区的朋友把她的豪猪木偶取名为黛布·科茨（Deb Cotes）。好吧，黛布·科茨是谁？所以黛布·科茨，她实际上和希瑟·海丁斯一起打过球，可能是我那个时代见过的最出色的球员就是黛布·科茨。连续的投篮，了不起的黛布·科茨。她是锦标赛得分王，到目前为止在三场比赛中得了 173 分，就是黛布·科茨。所以我们在文章中没有讨论的一件事是，像《得梅因纪事报》这样的报纸在支持这项运动方面发挥了多大的作用。女孩们从小就
reading about Deb Cotes and that's just something former players told me a lot just how nice it was for them to have role models that were girls from other small towns. Yeah, it's a huge deal. And especially the attention from the media, that's amazing. And as you know, the sport went on for generations. And so there's a ton of players we could talk about, but the very last person I need you to know about is Denise Long, because she was the first woman to ever be drafted to the NBA. Whoa, like the NBA, not the WNBA, the NBA. The NBA, NBA.
读着关于黛布·科茨的故事长大，这正是前球员们经常对我说的一点，拥有来自其他小镇的女孩作为榜样对她们来说是多么美好。是的，这是一件大事。尤其是来自媒体的关注，这太棒了。如你所知，这项运动延续了好几代人。所以我们可以讨论大量的球员，但你需要知道的最后一个人是丹尼斯·隆（Denise Long），因为她是历史上第一位被 NBA 选中的女性。哇，就像 NBA，而不是 WNBA，是 NBA。NBA，NBA。
This was 1969. She was selected in the 13th round by the then San Francisco Warriors. It was mostly a publicity stunt and that the owner of the Warriors had no intention of her playing with the men. He just wanted to start a professional women's basketball league with Denise Long as a star. So how did he know about a high schooler who played six on sex in Iowa? Yeah, I know. Well, so here's the thing. National News outlets started covering the Iowa girls basketball phenomenon actually as far back as the 40s, though I will say a lot of the coverage was kind of weird and sexist.
那是 1969 年。她在第 13 轮被当时的旧金山勇士队选中。这主要是一个宣传噱头，勇士队的老板根本没打算让她和男人们一起打球。他只是想以丹尼斯·隆为明星，创办一个职业女子篮球联盟。那么他是怎么知道一个在爱荷华州打六人制的高中生的呢？是的，我知道。好吧，事情是这样的。全国新闻媒体其实早在 40 年代就开始报道爱荷华州女子篮球现象了，虽然我得说很多报道都有点奇怪且带有性别偏见。
But Denise once scored 111 points, which means she shares the record for the most points scored ever in a six on six game. And you know what? That like really stuck out to people. Yeah, I would imagine so. I mean, it's such a notable part of the six on six history is that several people have scored 100 points or more in a game, and at least in the NBA, that would be just unheard of. I mean, only will Chamberlain did it back in the early 1960s. Yeah, and Denise even met him once. She remembers him telling her,
但丹尼斯曾经得到过 111 分，这意味着她保持着六人制比赛中单场最高得分的纪录。你知道吗？这真的让人印象深刻。是的，我想是的。我的意思是，六人制历史中最显著的一部分就是，有几个人在一场比赛中得到了 100 分或更多，至少在 NBA，这简直闻所未闻。我的意思是，只有威尔·张伯伦在 20 世纪 60 年代初做到过这一点。是的，丹尼斯甚至还见过他一次。她记得他对她说，
aren't you the young lady who broke my record? Let's hope that's so good. It's nice of him to recognize that. Yeah, so there are all kinds of stories about Denise, who even ended up being a guest on Johnny Carson because of all of this, but the Denise story I want to end on is the 1968 state tournament finals. And I've seen it called the game of the century. Now the big moment has arrived.
“你不是打破我纪录的那位年轻女士吗？”希望如此，这太好了。他能认出这一点真好。是的，关于丹尼斯的故事形形色色，由于这一切，她甚至最终成为了强尼·卡森节目的嘉宾，但我想要以之结束的丹尼斯的故事是 1968 年的州锦标赛决赛。我看到它被称为世纪之战。现在重大时刻来临了。
The championship game between Everly and Union Whitten. A meeting that's been brewing for four months of the regular season and now has reached the boiling point in this tournament. Denise was on Union Whitten, so was her cousin Cindy who was also a very impressive player. It was their school's first time at state. Denise is only 16 years old at the time but she's already won over the entire state of Iowa. Denny's long is the girl who has electrified this tournament like no other player in its 42-year history. The media was also really excited about this face-off because Everly, the other team,
埃弗利（Everly）和尤宁惠滕（Union Whitten）之间的冠军赛。这场对决在常规赛的四个月里一直在酝酿，现在在这场锦标赛中达到了白热化。丹尼斯效力于尤宁惠滕队，她的表妹辛迪（Cindy）也是如此，她也是一位非常出色的球员。这是他们学校第一次参加州锦标赛。丹尼斯当时只有 16 岁，但她已经征服了整个爱荷华州。丹尼斯·隆就是那个在其 42 年历史上以其他任何球员都无法比拟的方式让这场锦标赛沸腾的女孩。媒体也对这场对决感到非常兴奋，因为另一支球队埃弗利，
they also had a star player. In the forward court, the veteran is Janette Olson, the great jump shot specialist who led her team to the state title two years ago as a sophomore and now is back better than ever. Jenette average 58 points. So what happened in this game? I'm glad you asked because I watched the entire game on YouTube. And the first thing I want to reiterate is just how fun the sport is to watch. And I realized that the pace actually reminds me of hockey because there's like this constant
他们也有一位明星球员。在锋线上，老将珍妮特·奥尔森（Jeannette Olson）是伟大的跳投专家，她在两年前作为大二学生带领球队夺得了州冠军，现在她带着更好的状态归来。珍妮特场均得到 58 分。那么这场比赛究竟发生了什么？我很高兴你问起，因为我在 YouTube 上看完了整场比赛。我想重申的第一件事就是这项运动观看起来是多么有趣。我意识到比赛节奏实际上让我想到了曲棍球，因为球在
movement of the ball from one end to the next. But it's funny though because of the six on six rules, Denise and Jeanette didn't ever face off directly against each other. Oh right because they're both forward. So they stay on their half of the court. So they never actually come into contact. Yeah. And what that means is that when the ball wasn't on their side of the court, they could just watch the other person play and they kind of built up this mutual admiration. That's so amazing. So how did the game in the century shake out? Well, it's a super tight game. And with 45 seconds to go, it's 101 to 95. And it seems like Denise Long's team, Union Witten is going to be able to hold out for the win
一端到另一端之间有着持续的移动。但有趣的是，由于六人制规则，丹尼斯和珍妮特从未直接对位过。哦对了，因为她们都是前锋。所以她们留在自己半场的球场上。因此她们实际上从未产生接触。是的。这意味着当球不在她们那一侧的球场时，她们可以只是看着另一个人打球，她们有点建立起这种相互钦佩。太棒了。那么世纪之战的结果如何呢？嗯，这是一场非常胶着的比赛。比赛还剩 45 秒时，比分是 101 比 95。看起来丹尼斯·隆的球队尤宁惠滕将能够坚持到胜利
But then Jeanette Olson nails two shots now there are only two points behind and then with three seconds to go Olson gets fouled So she has two free throws and if she makes them she can tie the gate. Yeah, can you imagine that pressure? I cannot. Get an action with the weight of the world on her shoulders. A pressure ball player goes to the line. Right, watch her.
但随后珍妮特·奥尔森连进两球，现在她们只落后两分，接着在比赛还剩 3 秒时，奥尔森遭遇犯规，所以她获得了两次罚球机会，如果她罚中，就能扳平比分。是的，你能想象那种压力吗？我不能。一个背负着世界重压的球员走上了罚球线。没错，看着她。
What do you think happens? I mean, for it to be the game of the century, I think she has to make the shot. Yeah, she's super confident and sinks them both. What's up? It's a good, the score is hard. So she makes the shots, but there's still three seconds left. And there's a turnover and she gets one more shot and she misses. And I literally gasped at this moment, even though I knew what was happening
你觉得会发生什么？我的意思是，既然是世纪之战，我觉得她一定得把球投进。是的，她超级自信，两罚全中。怎么了？很好，比分很焦灼。所以她罚中了，但还剩 3 秒。然后出现了一次失误，她得到了最后一次投篮机会，却没投进。我在这一刻简直倒吸了一口凉气，尽管我早就知道结果会怎样，
because the title, the score was on the title of the YouTube. Anyways, it goes into overtime. Union Witten takes a four point lead and they just hold on to it. And so the very end of the game, it's 113 to 107. They got a left shot as well, crazy. And you can't tell the winners for the loses because the last five, the last five,
因为冠军头衔、比分就写在 YouTube 视频的标题上。无论如何，比赛进入了加时赛。尤宁惠滕取得了四分的领先优势并一直保持到最后。比赛的最后时刻，比分是 113 比 107。她们也进行了最后一次投篮，太疯狂了。你分不清谁是赢家谁是输家，因为最后五分钟，最后五分钟，
the greatest finish they've ever seen. Well, that's so great. It was a wild ride and I have one last thing to share with you. There's this book about the history of the jump shot called Rise and Fire and there's a whole chapter actually dedicated to this game. The author visited both Denise and Jeanette in 2014. And Jeanette showed him a letter she got from Denise just a few days after the 1968 title game. And I just wanna read you a little excerpt from it. Remember, she would've been 16 years old when she wrote this.
这是他们见过的最伟大的结局。嗯，太棒了。这是一场疯狂的旅程，我还有最后一件事要与你分享。有一本关于跳投历史的书叫《崛起与投篮》（Rise and Fire），其中甚至有一整章专门用来介绍这场比赛。作者在 2014 年拜访了丹尼斯和珍妮特。珍妮特向他展示了一封她在 1968 年冠军赛后几天收到丹尼斯的信。我只想给你读一读其中的一小段节选。记住，她写这封信时才 16 岁。
Okay. I think you're the best BB player I've ever seen and I mean that. There will never be a player like you, never. Just because you didn't win the state championship, it didn't take any points away from you being the greatest player because you are. I just felt privileged to be able to stand beside you on the all tournament team.
好的。我认为你是我见过的最好的篮球运动员，我是认真的。永远不会有像你这样的球员，永远不会。仅仅因为你没有赢得州冠军，并没有抹杀你作为最伟大球员的资格，因为你就是。我只是感到非常荣幸能够和你并肩站在全明星阵容中。
That is so sweet. That makes me so happy. Well, thank you for sharing it. I really appreciate it. Thank you. 99% invisible was produced this week by Ellie Gordon-Morchell, edited by Jason De Leon. Original music by Swan Rial, sound mix by Casey Holford, fact checking by Graham Haysha. Delaney Hall is our senior editor,
这太甜蜜了。这让我感到非常高兴。嗯，谢谢你分享。我真的很感激。谢谢。本周的《99%无形》由埃利·戈ードン-莫切尔（Ellie Gordon-Morchell）制作，杰森·德莱昂（Jason De Leon）剪辑。原创音乐由斯旺·里阿尔（Swan Rial）创作，声音混音由凯西·霍尔福德（Casey Holford）完成，事实核查由格雷厄姆·海沙（Graham Haysha）负责。德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们的资深编辑，
Kirk Colstad is our digital director. The rest of the team includes Chris Barupay, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lashemadon, Jacob Maldonada Medina, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars. The 99% invisible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. Special thanks this week to Max McAwayne, whose book, The Only Dance in Iowa, a history of six-player girls basketball, was crucial to the research for this story, as well as shattering the glass, the remarkable history of women's basketball by Pamela Grundy and Susan Schackelford.
柯克·科尔斯塔德（Kirk Colstad）是我们的数字总监。团队的其他成员包括克里斯·巴鲁派（Chris Barupay）、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）、维维安·莉（Vivian Leigh）、拉谢马顿（Lashemadon）、雅各布·马尔多纳达·梅迪纳（Jacob Maldonada Medina）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我——罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。《99%无形》的标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）设计。本周要特别感谢马克·麦克阿韦恩（Max McAwayne），他的书《爱荷华州唯一的舞蹈：六人制女子篮球史》（The Only Dance in Iowa, a history of six-player girls basketball）对这个故事的研究至关重要，还要感谢帕梅拉·格伦迪（Pamela Grundy）和苏珊·沙克尔福德（Susan Schackelford）撰写的《打破玻璃：女子篮球的卓越历史》（Shattering the Glass, the remarkable history of women's basketball）。
Additional thanks to the Iowa Women's Archives and a special shout-out for all the enthusiastic support from the I-Plate 6 on 6 Basketball in Iowa Facebook Group. Ellie also has a super fun podcast about the film, Dirty Dancing, a scene by scene breakdown of Dirty Dancing called, But Out Baby, which you should definitely check out. 99% invisible is part of the Stitcher and Serious XM podcast family.
还要感谢爱荷华州妇女档案馆（Iowa Women's Archives），并特别感谢 Facebook 群组“爱荷华州我爱六人制篮球”（I-Plate 6 on 6 Basketball in Iowa）所有热情的支持。埃利还有一个非常有趣的播客，关于电影《辣身舞》（Dirty Dancing），对《辣身舞》进行了逐场分解，名为《但愿如此，宝贝》（But Out Baby），你绝对应该去听听。《99%无形》是 Stitcher 和 Sirius XM 播客大家庭的一部分。
Now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI org. Or on Instagram, Reddit and TikTok too. You can find links to others to your shows I love as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
目前总部设在潘多拉大厦以北六个街区。位于加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市区北部。你可以在 Facebook 上找到节目并参与有关节目的讨论。你可以在 Twitter 上@我（@Roman Mars），也可以@节目（@99PI org）。或者在 Instagram、Reddit 和 TikTok 上也能找到我们。你可以在 99PI.org 上找到我喜爱的其他节目的链接以及 99PI 的每一期过往节目。你本期节目还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。